[Applaudissements]
bon je vais bosser par un point la
colère non sur la première alors vous
allez voir c'est lui qui vient de tf1
donc c'est vraiment le style tf1 n'est
brassée
il est propre regardez lui la voilà je
peux faire ça il est propre il est
toujours propre et ça sent bon ont pesé
gratuit que j'ai pu m'en rends pas du
tout pas tarder à me faire chier suite
alors qu'est-ce qui va qu'est ce que tu
vas faire un moment déjà j'ai pu me
payer ma chronique par rapport à lundi
on a fait des petits ajustements vous
allez retrouver plein de nouveautés on
va commencer avec le flash backs et les
images que j'ai regardé depuis ce matin
jusqu'à hier à ces flashbacks en fait
des flash backs de l'éducation nationale
jean michel blanquer air qui a connu
quelques galères avec la réforme sur
l'accord du participe passé
un comble j'en ai mangé des crêpes
virgule j'en ai mangé
oui aussi et est maintenant c'est nous
et non c'était et des crêpes j'en ai
mangé nos amis la régie de cellulite
cependant la diffusion du documentaire
sont didier deschamps hier soir faisait
des tests techniques en live et du coup
on a entendu leurs voix tranquille on a
pu en profitèrent écouter bien sûr le
secret de mon chalet du monde
ça s'est vraiment passé hier soir c'est
bon je suis hyper content tanguy devant
les journalistes sur bfm paris nous a
fait coucou sont rapidement
trois d'entre eux à la il savait pas
qu'il était à l'antenne enfin eric
woerth le président de la commission des
finances était l'invité de bfm hier soir
pour parler de la réforme de l'impôt est
apparemment même pour lui ça un petit
peu compliqué répond qui n'apporte ni
compétitivité ni pouvoir d'achat dit ni
ni délit
pisa sion vous sachiez un truc aussi ses
armes en france et 3 - gaillard voilà ce
lipide paie ma chronique wahaha alors
instauré m6 diffusait la finale de son
jeu d aventure pékin express une coursed
aventure avec un euro par jour
en fait c'est un peu être comme elle
chronique et enfanter pmp un ça à peu
près de même tarif et qui dit tu es de
merck va retourner travailler beaucoup
et qui dit qu'on se dit candidat à bloc
qui n'arrête pas de cas va les regarder
c'est parti réconfortant quand on les
lâche pas d'une semelle gros il faut
fini encore en tout cas on a voulu
répondre à cette question pourquoi
courtine aussi vite et bien nos
candidats et ils croient tout simplement
après l'argent en finale le temps c'est
de l'argent
dans cette finale le temps c'est de
l'argent c'est un amusement et le temps
c'est de l'argent
le temps en c'est de l'argent assez de
l'arche c'est d'argent le temps c'est de
l'argent et ça on le comprend bien tout
au long du programme un peu le temps
c'est de l'argent
dans cette finale et avait derek très
très compliqué il fallait un pack +16 va
se composer de trois sprints
intermédiaires de 10 euros par seconde
600 euros la minute 18000 euros la
demi-heure en six mille euros le sait
bien que les mineurs vous participer à
un quiz tant qu'ils n'auront pas 5
bonnes réponses
ils ne pourront pas reprendre la route
les candidats vont devoir dominer
estimer le poids d'un riche y créer une
trois sprints intermédiaires fait où il
y aura le fameux sprint final vous
connaît quelques années on n'a pas monté
au-delà du sort on l'ajusté voulait en
fait c'est paris qui chie ces mots
initial j'aime bien le monde un enfant
cd christina et didier pour comprendre
leur victoire on a décortiqué les images
et on s'est rendu compte que didier il
avait dû au bois au moins une citerne de
café avant de démarrer à regarder
merci car j'espère vous
go ils ont aussi gagné grâce à une super
communication entre eux c'était d'une
limpidité exceptionel hors tu fais pas
demi tour par rapport à la liste
continue sur le chemin est ce que tu
comprends ce que même dire non je ne
comprends pas revoir l'épisode passant
le binôme s'est ressoudé un peu trop
même c'était limite gênant ça existe le
sag l'histoire pour ça glisse encore
didier attendant je sens je sens
sans pneu dur quand même bravo
bon sinon vous allez encore un petit peu
de temps pour terminer j'ai fouiné sur
internet j'ai tapé sur mon clavier j'ai
trouvé un peu comme bertrand et hier une
nouvelle youtube buzz
non ouais ouais pour questions des
téléspectateurs qui répondent qu'ils
sont les téléspectateurs il s'appelle le
mieux c'est de le découvrir au regard
des années salut un petit coup c'est
mokhtari la youtube buzz sur ben aminé
comme une clémentine titi j'ai reçu un
mail ru choupinou on me demande comment
battront chamerois passe autant dans les
coulisses de l'émission aura les images
[Musique]
ça doit faire mal au nougat ou s'est pas
dites couilles tu l'as acheté mon titre
ici maintenant et on termine avec un fan
zone qui a vu valérie benaïm passer à la
télévision sont un esprit la coquine
mais rien à voir la force pour le borgne
bon
[Applaudissements]
athènes
[Rires]
sa cavale est ce que j'avais sous
serment
voilà c'est aussi fini dos rond sur
votre très vite
en attendant moi je vais me faire épiler
dsm les jambes
[Applaudissements]
ça viendra tous les jeudis c'est fait
vous savez que je dis c'est sûr et
certain
aux alentours de 19h50 grâce à bravo
merci vous valez rien et désolé en
rivière de toile f1 s'excuse derrière si
tous a annoncé que jamais au sort
[Applaudissements]